[Musique]
il l'a brandisse fièrement la coupe des
Yvelines et cette année pour eux les
joueurs d'Aubergenville tomber en finale
de l'équipe réserve de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine le score final
3-0 une fierté une grande fierté c'est
la première fois qu'on ramène un trophée
en tout cas la coupe des Yvelines
seniors à la ville donc en tout cas nous
on est très contents une première
mi-temps accrochée entre les deux
équipes des fautes mais pas de bus en
deuxième mi-temps Aubergenville est
enfin libéré le capitaine et président
du club ouvre le score
les aubergenvillois profitent de cette
bonne période en inscrivant deux autres
buts c'est le numéro 12 qui marque 11
minutes ensuite en éliminant défenseur
et gardien le troisième est marqué par
le numéro 8 il est éteint tous les
espoirs de remonter au score pour les
conflamer
[Applaudissements]
ils sont obligés de sortir de se
découvrir quand on arrive à mettre un
deuxième puis un troisième
un peu stressante parce que du coup on
arrive pas à marquer on n'arrive pas à
débloquer la situation après une bonne
équipe de Conflans en face de nous voilà
qu'on a su être patient on a su
continuer à mettre notre jeu en place et
en tout cas pour moi c'est une très
grande fierté parce que malgré l'enjeu
on a continué à développer notre jeu
mettre en place qu'on a travaillé toute
l'année donc honnêtement c'est un réel
plaisir face à eux les joueurs de
Conflans 2 sont dans le dur l'équipe ne
convient pas s'exprimer plusieurs
blessures ont émaillé le match les côtes
je voudrais un bilan amer pas mal de
déception
on avait préparé le match comme il
fallait en tout cas on pensait et on a
fait aujourd'hui à nos matchs
que ce soit techniquement tactiquement
ou autre on n'a pas répondu présent et
je m'en excuse auprès des supporters de
Conflans et du club un peu de pression
et on s'est vu un peu trop trop beau je
pense on n'était pas prêt on n'a pas
l'expérience de jouer ce genre de match
et il faut le prendre comme une bonne
expérience ce type de match même si on a
perdu un titre en couple mais pas de
montée dans le championnat de première
division pour Aubergenville cette année
c'est donc l'objectif pour la prochaine
saison voir inscrire une deuxième fois
son nom au palmarès de la coupe des
Yvelines